get this guy
over there
its pitch black we got our anchor line
out and so to a bunch of other boats
around us we got to make sure that our
fish doesn't come in contact with any of
the other anchor lines in the water or
will be a huge paycheck this is going
crazy right now we got the anchor line
right here we're trying to back away
from the anchor we get everything we
should be in good position definitely a
big pointy Rock your online straight
ahead and get outta here around
come on another guy hanging all over
here we can use this business
now we've got a guy right here stretched
out gonna get a tanker back to drag on
too
he's getting wrapped in brokeback that
dragon fact that dragged off
the background of this guy thanks thanks
like I was kind enough to get off the
blanket for
Thank you Thank right now are fishes
wrapped around him another guys anchor
ball and our goal is to get the anchor
ball and untangle it without losing our
fish don't put any pressure on Captain
happen
hurry up there you go on
awesome
wrong
so much like I don't want to cut the guy
thank you do as much as it sucks
I'd rather lose a fish then do something
crappy to another fisherman I just don't
need the bad karma my vote now you can
do is go back up on again that lights at
least thanks to drop anchor appreciate
it but no problem to you on them
yup Tyler lost a fish awesome it
good going them and debate you're right
call and all my years efficient you know
I've learned one thing you got to try
and put out good karma and usually good
kamar results a good fishing in return
[Music]